rarement au québec voit-on tant de
personnes noires sur un tapis rouge des
cinéphiles heureux de se voir
représentés à l'écran et qui se
souviennent des films qui les ont
inspirés un prince à new york et le film
qui m'a marqué le plus que j'ai écouté
29 fois que de l'akp à tous pourquoi
parce que j'ai trouvé que c'était
l'esprit moderne de de cette révolution
noire et tout la présence des noirs à
l'écran et derrière la caméra remonte
aux balbutiements du cinéma
dès 1919 oscar michaud et le premier
afro-américain à écrire réaliser et
produire un film mais il faudra attendre
1940 pour qu une afro américaine
remporte un premier oscar l'actrice
hattie mcdaniel qui récompensé pour son
rôle dans le film autant en emporte le
vent durant les années 60
sidney poitier s'impose comme une star
incontournable à hollywood et dans le
bouillonnement des années 70 apparaît la
blaxploitation un courant qui offre aux
noirs des rôles de premier plan le
succès de spike lee marque un nouveau
tournant à la fin des années 80
ton histoire fait penser un peu à xavier
dolan du commandant sow ce que tu as
fait ton 1er juin avec presque rien mais
que tu as tellement entêté et déterminé
à faire ce que tu as à faire que voilà
ça finit par faire en sorte que les gens
puissent se reconnaître mon père est un
travail c'était vraiment une histoire
universelle qui mettait en vedette cette
nouvelle cohorte de nouveaux talents
convoi jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]
le star système évolue effet de plus en
plus de place aux stars de couleur tu me
rends marqué ses terres que nous tous la
fim qui me rend marqué parce que je
voyais à la télé j'ai des jeunes noirs
dans une école plus récemment le succès
aux oscars de moonlight l'histoire d'une
vie a été un autre moment marquant dans
l'histoire du cinéma afro américains il
traite de sujets plus relié à la
communauté lgbt et en même temps avec la
comment comment comment on vit son
homosexualité qu'on est typé comiques
comme le rôle principal du film lui les
plus geeks teurs affiché comme kingston
homme fort et que le terrain mais là on
brise tous les stéréotypes
jusqu'à dimanche le festival
international du film black permet de
découvrir des films de partout sur la
planète qui s'inspireront peut-être dans
la grande histoire du cinéma ici nabli
alexandre charti radio canada montréal